good luck to my opponents
okay this is a slightly annoying opening
uh maybe I'll play G6
play G6 and ducky 2. maybe we can do a
quick pull too
um
is this your first time seeing duck
chess
is this your first time seeing duck
chess
yes no oh I should have played duck at
D3
oh that's okay
okay I'm playing like some kind of
modern Pierce opening
but opening theory is completely ruined
in this game because the doc just blocks
moves that I want to play it's kind of
annoying
let's develop
ducky two
[Music]
hitting the pawn now
so the duck is shared it belongs to both
of us
after every turn you get to place it on
an empty Square
child
hey congrats to spooky cat
becoming a spooky cat child
yeah this is kind of annoying
takes
and
I feel like I'm already Under Pressure
here
but I can play 95 which looks like a
blunder is a knight but then I put the
duck
on D3
and now I'm hitting the bishop
what the duck I am in shambles there is
a waterfowl in my favorite game
oh no my waterfowl
yeah
I'm still very new to this
I mean this opening
I'm kind of just winging it
C6 Maybe
ah there's no need actually
yeah the Knight is defended by the duck
not too upset about this opening
maybe I should have played no I had to
keep them duck
okay let's put it here and then here
oh is it touch duck rule maybe an over
the board
uh how to do this there's almost cool
tactics but they don't quite work
I think I can take the pawn actually
take the pawn now
and then put the dock on F4
so I blocked the Bishop from
covering E5
oh this wasn't good though or was it I'm
allowing this this
wait a minute
oh
what did I do
I just plundered a piece I forgot duck
F6 was possible
ah
I can do this and then this
and now the King has to maybe take
or the Knight
that was very confusing though
I can develop
I'm treating this like a Gambit
and I want to put this
is what I want to do next
let's flashing move the duck but I don't
know where to move it
um
I have a funny idea I'm gonna put that
on d8
that way the duck cannot be placed on d8
next turn
because I want the castle next I guess
the duck can be on CA next turn
it's a weird idea though to put the duck
on a square that's like in my way
because then the point will have to move
it to somewhere else
it's a weird concept
okay now let's check
there's no check in this game by the way
um
cocky too I shouldn't overthink this
I'm down a piece but I feel like there's
nice compensation
so now I have a fork
Kentucky two
oh this is problematic this looks like
checkmates but the king can move here
and that can block so that's the game is
going to go on but I'm gonna win the
Rook
yeah this is really nice now
foreign
so my early piece blunder sacrifice paid
off
oh wow it's about 50 50.
so I assume a lot of people have seen
duck chess from like the recent YouTube
video
uh Jeezy
yeah in this game capturing the king
ends the game and it is legal to just
put your King on a square that's hanging
so I have to be careful not to make
illegal moves
or make moves that hang the king
okay I'll play this person
so I assume I'm playing viewers like I
assume that the people challenging me
are probably like watching the Stream
waiting for a game to finish
and sending the challenge
so I hope people enjoy this I mean it's
it's different
it's not what I'm used to
I discovered this opening the other day
it's like an alkyne
but I prevent the night
a night from uh moving to D5 I'll play
D4
quack
although to Triple Forks
cracked triple Forks
it feels so good putting my dog into
Poland's territory like that
but it feels bad when they put in my
territory
okay a few people enjoying it
oh we can change the time controls
that's a reasonable suggestion I think
five plus four is like the default
I don't mind this this gives me time to
kind of think
and try and explain things
so Bishop wants to go here
is still ready to
develop
I'm keeping the dock on the D file to
avoid the queen dragon
if I could take
oh I have to move a piece first let's
Castle
very restrictive this probably gives me
a lot of space the duck gives me even
more
potential
Knight H6 okay black wants a castle so
maybe I'll play Queen E2 and duck
f8
I'm allowing Bishop G4 though so maybe
I'll play this
mcnabbits with the bits saying white
definitely has a major advantage
also thank you Peter shout out to Peter
oh yeah white can play E4 and then block
that is true
that's very true
also think you crab with top hat the
double quack
's surviving here though I I'm I did try
and use my opening advantage to its
fullest
we have a position
chief
you guys should take actually take and
play
duck D7
I think in this game Bishops are just
less powerful than Knights
okay this is annoying I'll put a rook on
D1
and I'll probably rock on E1
maybe I can go for E6 soon
oh Peter says you're welcome great games
with Magnus and Fabiano
it's just Dawning on me I played Magnus
and Fabiano
within the span of a few weeks
and we both have we like all both games
were like super fun and they were
recorded for content
I think it's it's beginning to sink in
uh let's play this and then this
I want to bring the queen and
attack the king side
I didn't play Magnus today I played
Magnus a few weeks ago
at the singfield Cup Opening Ceremony my
videos on YouTube
it was one of the few games he played in
St Louis
before uh withdrawing and leaving town
okay finally I can play Rook D1
this game is actually really positional
at least in the earlier stages
at some point it could get more Tactical
but thus far it's been a matter of
improving
uh winning a free Pawn black wants to
win this Pawn so I'll play duck B7
and I am aimed at the queen
oh
okay now I can win another Pawn
and where should the duck go maybe here
still covering these B2
logging the rook and Bishop
so now we're gonna see a very common
type of tactic in this game where I take
the Rook
it looks like oh no my queen but then I
just play this and I want a free rook
so distance or distant defensive
um
what's the right word
distant defenses
are not that effective when there's a
duck that can block it
so
wait did what's happening oh the duck
moved from D to C8
so it's important that I can still uh
keep the dock between the Queens
so I'm up a rook here
hmm
those pawns attack
and my Queen's attacked
I'm looking at this move
now there's a funny idea
if I play this move I have to put the
dog on C8
no let's let's be a little bit more
conservative
look at this and duck D5
defending F3
also hitting both Pawns
another thing about this game double
attacks are not always so effective
because in this case E Pawn can move and
the duck can be placed on A6
and sharing both pawns are defended
so there are ways to cope with double
attacks
that you can't usually do in normal
chess
suggested OTB rules when placing the
duck you have to squeak it
would be a great rule they really need a
quack sound effect
maybe for the next game I can look up
some
ambient
duck sounds
and see what will pop up on YouTube
[Music]
okay
so I can take
take this Pawn
put the duck here
I might be ready to play Queen D5 Duck's
gonna have to
although the ducks in my way now
uh let's take and play attack F6
so Rook is safe
this Pawn is hanging though
I actually have to be really careful
yeah let's play this and move back
actually wasn't necessary because the
Knight was defending the Rook
be careful of my king
so maybe now I take and then
block the check with a duck
now when I say block the check
um in normal chassis of course would be
check in Duck chess there's really no
such thing as check
but it's still kind of an idea
uh let's play this move
and then duck I don't know where I want
to put the duck
G4
okay so I'm hitting the king and queen
realizing this this is possible
but then I don't think that would work
okay so here we see another example uh
it looks like the Queen's defended but I
take the queen
and I played Doc F7
and uh the rook's blocked I just want my
free Queen
oh yes my duck
don't don't mess with my dog
yo nice I just watched the duck chess
video on YouTube
wait which one
did I only post one
oh yeah there's one
doctor's video
I actually I schedule another one to be
released in
like a minute
I think
it's scheduled to be released at 5 30
Central Time
I keep vlogging this check with the duck
um
okay so one thing I'm not that great at
is like finishing the game
um I have enough time here to like try
and think through things
so
how to do maybe like Queen F4
and then duck
I'm just making sure there's enough
things between their rook and the King
did I miss a freaking
I don't think I did
unless I did
oh people are suggesting duck g8s
which is now no longer possible
okay let's play this and then this I
just want to bring the queen in
later I can maybe go back and see if
there was a quicker wind
yeah so this is actually really cool
because now I can put the duck oh no I
can't ah
okay I guess I'll take the pawn and put
the duck here
I wanted to play duck G7 or queen G7 dog
F7
oppon's gonna be flagging very soon
okay so that was some small repetition
yeah like I'm okay so here I can play
Queen G7 duck F7 I think this is just
game over because there's no way for the
King to just survive like the King has
to take basically
and then wherever the duck moves I take
the king
okay
okay that was a satisfying finish
foreign
yeah so for example
if I had played Queen G7 like F6 this
would be a blunder because opponent
could take and then block
so you always have to keep in mind
the deviousness of the duck
also happy 20 months
it's a late night Life Alert
okay I'll accept this challenge
yeah like every turn you have to move
the duck you can't keep the duck on the
Square that it's on which makes things
interesting
leads to some maybe more abstract oh
that's funny wow
so this was a great example of that
uh like in this position
[Music]
I'm gonna have to okay let's play Bishop
T4
I'm gonna have to move the duck away
from B7 so wherever I put the duck black
is guaranteed to play Bishop B7
very clever
okay let's defend the pawn I still like
the duck on E6 I feel like the fact that
the Box upon makes
life very difficult for black
it's always funny seeing these comments
of people just joining asking why is
there a duck on the board
um just watch and hopefully you'll
understand the basic thing to know is a
duck cannot be moved through it cannot
be captured we T we take turns making
moves and putting the ducks or putting
the duck on a new empty Square
that's the simplest explanation I can
give
people can try this on their own too
it's chess.com variants
and there's a bunch of different
variants to play but uh yeah this is
duck chess which I think was added not
too long ago
we only discovered it a few days ago
oh yeah we have the rules here too
sorry if they're a little bit small
okay I think E5 is called for at some
point
whoa thanks so much startle cubits the
10 gifted
really appreciate that
also welcome back
yeah all the subs got access to the the
goose emotes but I don't have a duck
emoji yet
maybe I'm due for one
uh let's play this
I've returned so far like we can see
notation every turn I've been pulling
the dock on E6
being very stubborn
now I think what what black should have
done there was play B4 and duck E5 or
duck D5 preventing Knight T5
and now there's some tension between the
knights yeah it's very difficult to get
a staffer cabinet in this game
because inevitably the dog will
interfere with things
Queen D7
so I'm just going for the bishop for
nitrate
ooh
okay now
it probably makes sense to put the duck
on the Square the Knight wants to move
to
just probably a five
actually it's interesting
where to put the duck
A5 A7 or B8
probably A5
that way the duck now has to move to one
of these sad squares
now there's a funny idea to play this
and then this
this is where the duck Tactics come in
because now
get a Bishop's plot
and yeah now the the duck is going to
have to stay like on this kind of
diagonal
um
how to do this probably Bishop
the bishop back and put the duck back so
we're gonna get a situation where we
keep moving the duck back and forth
between C6 and B5
and it's gonna be my opponent putting
the dock on B5 and me playing the dock
on C6 so The Bishop's always going to be
blocked
uh when it comes to taking the pawn
I play rookie six
looks like a fun move
now I think the key here is to
create an additional method of attacking
I'll put the queen in
opponents and ducks ducks along as
opposed to zugz Wang
I was wondering if we would see castling
but that hangs a queen
uh let's put the duck on each one
I put the dock on each one so my
opponent has to move the mouse really
far too
move it somewhere else
it's still saving my Pawn
oh fancy
okay lingering tension
okay black wants to trap the bishop
so what I can do is play this and then
each doc H4
preventing Pawn H4
oh but I'm losing this Pawn but maybe
I'm winning the spawn
I think it was uh I was gonna say a
little bit better to keep the talk on
each form but the duck had to move
so now let's play this and then this
and now I just take the pawn and yeah
that was a a distant defense so
Free Pawn
the duck cannot capture the duck is
incapable of capturing
it has to move to an empty Square so now
I'm putting it on B7 which looks
countered productive
counterproductive
but um it forces the opponent to move
the duck away from B7
the next move
which they do
and now I can play this I'm like I'm
squirming my way in now the duck's gonna
have to be removed from C6 and I might
win the bishop for free
I also might just be meeting very soon
and black isn't a big predicament I mean
this is possible
maybe but others
big things to worry about here for black
now check
maybe check in this
oh wait no I have to be careful wait
what did I do
I have to play ducky seven
otherwise I'd lose a queen
okay
it's kind of close
we're very close to getting a duck meat
so the Queen's taken
which is legal then the opponent has to
move the duck somewhere and it loses a
king
so oh no my queen
it's funny also when you play a move
and you haven't moved the dock yet then
you can't take back the move that you
played
oh look at this queen C8
and duck d8
I think this is game over
man this game went so swimmingly
because the duck has to move away from
d8 and it's gonna
unleash the attack against the king
yeah so I guess this is one example of a
duck mate
the very informal term
okay
gain some reading
I'm on the quest
to be the duck Chess World Champion
getting another challenge I'll play a
few more
this is chess.com variants
they have a bunch of variants
to play
here I'm just playing viewers
and it's it's a whole new world like
when you add this element of the duck
there's a lot to get used to
you before
to play play D5
I should have played duck E3 keep
forgetting my opening crap
okay so now we'll play Let's Play Bishop
G4 and duck E3
we might see this move
and gain Tempo on the bishop
ooh
I should have put the duck on E6
I'm still learning
okay now we're gonna have a scenario
where um
yeah we'll be moving
the duck probably to to these squares
oh
play this and this
that would be fun to play Levy in this
game
duck match
he wanted to chest box me
which I guess in chess boxing there's
also the element of
docking
to duck the punches
so I do have a thread here we'll see if
my opponent deals with a threat
opponent is not so I can take
again this was a long distance defense
and I've gone up upon
now I'm sure it would be pretty simple
to make a browser extension
that just programs a quack every time
the piece has moved
oh I wanted to find ambient duck noises
this is an hour-long video
oh okay let's let's skip to the exciting
part
foreign
how many people enjoy this and how many
people hate it
I hope I don't get like copyright struck
it's not like a
top song or anything
it's actually kind of relaxing
okay we have the pole
yeah some people are more sensitive to
the noises than others
okay
is it too loud
turn it down a little bit
oh
oh wait oh wow if I take the pawn oh
that was so clever if I take the pawn
and lose a knight
I was about to fall for it too
Poland probably said oh no my palm
so 68 of people
say yes to dark noises
Queen E2 very fine move
Your Castle what A5 out though A5 takes
and then duck A7
what place he sits
are they still loud sorry about that
I can uh
I made it a little bit quieter
and there's a lot of ducks in this video
I want to find a place like this
and then record my own duck noises
it would be cool to do in real life dog
chess where you play on a giant
chessboard
and you have like a real life duck
walking around
and then instead of like picking up the
dock and placing it on Square every move
you just let the dog the duck roam
around
and you can't move through it
that would be fun
okay let's um let's play this
and then this
I actually I saw what was it
last time I had like a nice duck
encounter
it was about a year ago
I went to this National Park
in Utah
and
there were there were a decent number of
ducks
and this is these are some photos I took
the Ducks were pretty impressed with the
soccer Gambit
but they were behind the fence so they
couldn't actually like
roam around on the chessboard
[Music]
are you here
yeah one of the Ducks had like a really
cool haircut
look at this duck
just chilling and enjoying its nice hair
wait hair or feathers
maybe feathers
also wow what is this
take and play ducky three
um
I want to play this
it seems like the craziest move
and then duck C3
because the duck the duck is double
pinned so the bishop ends of the king
so white will have to move it off one of
the diagonals
oh dear weird but fun
well I hope you have hope you're having
fun hope it's not too weird
welcome back to Neil
uh let's take and then talk
I think like C3 again
so I'm hitting the Rook
the final pole so two-thirds of people
prefer the duck noises
one third
say no
okay so now I can take and play this so
the knight's untakeable
and this is double check the King has to
move basically
and now I can take the rook and prevent
The Rook from taking my knight
big things for the dock
and now I can take the bishop and
prevent my knight from being captured
again
that one very swimmingly
okay now it's just like cicada noises
okay
raising the Rings
oh emberg okay I'll play Ember
emberg has been
I think watching for a while
you you had some message about ducks
earlier but I didn't address it
oh but it was it was about the history
of Doc chess
yeah we saw ducktrust.com earlier
okay still Theory
this is my duck chess Theory thus far
so I'm preventing the knight from moving
here
and I'm hitting the Knight with a pawn
and knights are so important this game
because
they're like most immune to the duck
okay
defend and play
maybe this
maybe this
so I'm hitting the dock or hitting the
Knight again
now that can like move the duck and
prevent me from taking but I'm ready to
play this Moon
and now I think the Knight is trapped
I I took away the H6 Square wow
oh it's so satisfying
yeah I didn't hit the dock well we gotta
be kind to the duck
so this is a funny opening trap
winning the night within four moves
I don't know where to put it
let's put it here
preventing the Bishop from developing
hmm
develop the bishop
oh okay so D5 I don't have to take
ambassan that's not a rule in this game
um but son's not forced
I'll take this pawn and play duck t7
so Queen is untakable
okay now the Queen's attacked
very clearly
um might as well take and play duck E2
so then that way my Bishop won't be
fully blocked
okay
back and play this
foreign
to show no mercy I still have all the
minor pieces
idea to Castle develop
okay this is actually a funny move so
I'm going to play Bishop B5 and then
duck C6
and that way it kind of forces the trade
of Bishops
also thank you go Abraham
seven with a sub
um
play this
ensuring I can play another three next
I can can I pre-move multiple oh I can't
pre-move on top of the duck
oh that's actually a funny like it's a
very minor bug
but generally you can pre-move
at least your next move with the piece
okay so we're gonna see how powerful
Knights will be in the middle game
oh thank you g Spades
yeah now we have the
the duck command
for everyone new tuning in that is
confused why there's a duck on the board
now there's a command to answer that
God's castle and play this
thank you cool case happy three months
okay preventing Rook t8s
oh I like the suggestion from
Costa cow
I miss the opportunity to name the
stream don't chest with my duck
I might have to steal that
I'm gonna play duck D6 forcing the
bishop back
foreign
first time chat saying thank you for the
game Eric
your night absolutely destroyed me
yeah uh a nights are Relentless in this
game
it takes patience though to like
gradually build up
okay now I'll play this and then
maybe maybe this actually this is
actually really nice I put the duck on
A5
because black will have to move the duck
away from A5
and I'm almost guaranteed to trap the
bishop
like if A6
I play A5 dog A7 if C6 I play A5 duck C7
so I'm curious if there is even a way to
save the bishop here
ah there is
okay I see the suggestion in chat
it's not so obvious though
oh
okay first things first let's win the
pawn
oh wait a minute
I forgot the Rook to take first I should
have played duck
should play duck G6 with duck G7
well I still have this idea though so it
shouldn't be too bad
yeah that was definitely not too bad
hmm
yeah open files aren't so useful in this
game
when the duck can just block them
okay making some progress
I'm dreaming of a time I play like Rook
d8 some sort of checkmate
like if the Rook moves I play Rook da
ducky 7. I think that's game over
I'll play C3 and duck C5
so the bishop can't return
okay let's get the other rook in
where do I want to put this C6
preventing Pawn C6
and now the idea is to lift the other
Rook
ooh
opponent's also getting very low on time
as far as I know there's no engine in
this variant
also Ono Black's King
it's so great that normally like Elite
the the moves that are normally illegal
are legal in this game
oh let's play Neil okay
Neil was commenting earlier that uh he
was watching this
or playing this
okay
um opening Theory
it's actually good that there's no
engine in this game because I think that
would ruin the fun
it also prevents any
any type of cheating really
right
I guess the only way to achieve this
game is to like
is to find a player who's better than
you tell you
but so far there's no duck engine
hopefully we can keep it that way
yeah strong engine would just probably
be too good at this
yeah I think I'm chopping the Knight
again
yeah
Also to clarify see there's one comment
saying I cheat with chats sometimes if
anyone suggests a move that's good that
I didn't see
uh then
it but that's my duty not to play it
um
but usually when I play like serious
chess I don't look at chat anyway
so I'll only like look after the fact to
address questions
and usually it's manageable
um and usually people are pretty good at
not like suggesting moves or even using
the engine to watch during games
I probably should have played ducky six
there
yeah let's play D4 and duck E6
and this is probably the most common
square to move the dock to early in the
game
hmm
I want to go for the throat
but how to do this and this and this
Neil offers a draw
taking a draw especially so early
it's against my ethics
oh okay so now I can play this and this
so the duck will have to move away from
G6
and black also can't play G6 so how does
black defend F7
and if Bishop E6 I taken and that pawn
will be pinned
O'Neill says I'm Mouse lift
oh no your mouse
where do I put
I'm just realizing
I kind of miscalculated
it's okay though I'll put the duck back
and we'll see what Neil does
it can sometimes be easy to Mouse to the
duck
it happened to me the other day
yeah nice move
uh the king is uh not attacked
hello Eric hello thanks for being an
inspiration
to play on leeches later today too
either way I hope you're having fun
um I actually already played on each ass
for
about four hours wow this this stream is
over five hours now I should
I should go outside and get some fresh
air
oh well
I didn't realize how long I've been
streaming this is just too much fun
though
uh let's play Let's play this and then
this
yeah I should really go outside have
some food
I this might be the last game
oh
Amberg muted the Stream
Hamburg says I'm using the stream for
our very first game together I didn't
know
I was in
in Duck
so I was crack mated
uh
yeah a good game member
I don't know where to put the duck
ah maybe maybe you see it and when the
when the night moves here I played Pawn
B3
and Knight will be trapped
yeah it's so interesting like the
ability to trap knights in this game
like upon attacking at night is actually
can be very powerful
in situations like this
oh you missed yeah um well earlier today
it was a warm-up Arena
and the title Arena
Point prevents Pawn B3
um
now I might just take you know I'm up
materials so
where do I want to put the docker
I need like E4
or maybe duct T2
just so that Bishop has some scope
yeah I'm realizing it's still hard to
effectively trap pieces when
the duck can prevent my moves too
okay so now let's play this
and maybe this
ah okay so a few moves ago I thought B3
would trap the Knight but you make a
good point that 95 Knight A5 and then
doc on the A5 though
um
yeah maybe Neil should have allowed that
and allowed me to play P3
can maybe now each five
yeah let's make some progress here
I'm gonna prevent the king from running
this way
try and keep the King on the king side
where it belongs
exalted says even though I lost all
games I still like the idea of this duck
chess game
that's nice it takes a lot of getting
used to
I've been
gradually learning
also I have a new Duck chess video
it was I guess it was released during
this stream over half hour ago
I was scheduled at 5 30.
the video is
don't mess with my duck
hope you are well mate
doing very well
talk as well
thank you to marcher NZ
okay so now we have this alignment
realizing another kind of key Concept in
this game is the principle of two
weaknesses
or the principle of two Targets
so having one attack like this is not
enough
oh wow casting kingside
wow
that was unexpected
that's a move though
play this and
maybe this
I'm blocking that file
foreign
[Music]
counseling was very very bold
okay so now I can take on E6
and move the duck back to F7
and now the Rook is trapped I'm not
interested in taking the Rook though
I'm also still wondering if night surge
is more powerful than Rooks in this game
it was very possibly they are
like The Rook is always going to be
Limited
I play they kind of play this and this
not sure if this works but it's
interesting
because if the queen takes a knight then
the duck has to move and I win the queen
also ready to take this thing
we might see this and then duck G5 but
then maybe I take
it's interesting
yeah let's take
wait a minute
the bishop could take back
but that's probably no good
yeah I saw that but now I thought I
could take and then play this again
opponents about the flag
oh
okay now I take the Rook
and let's put the duck here
right
looks good enough
yeah
wave was imminent too
Unless somehow black moved and put the
duck on G7 and then maybe I would have
been confused
oh a duck on each seven win
uh I don't understand where though
the King has to kind of be attacked to
win it though
good game Neil
okay I'm
I'm gonna end things I I need some fresh
air maybe I'll take a walk and see some
real life talks
I'll get some more challenges in the
future
but for now
um there's a lot of games ongoing I feel
partly responsible for this
uh if you want more duck content
you can watch Leia's YouTube video
it's 81 seconds
it's actually my second ever game of
duck chess
where
I don't want to spoil it
but it was probably the funniest game
I've played thus far